doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness pit stephen strange against some
unexpected villains and the biggest one
might be someone we all thought we knew
warning spoilers ahead for doctor
strange too the fate of the multiverse
depends on us prior to its release there
was a good deal of speculation as to
what kind of role the scarlet witch
would play in dr strange 2. wanda
maximoff has already gone through quite
the journey in the marvel cinematic
universe entering avengers age of ultron
as an antagonist until she joins up with
the good guys for the final fight she
remains a force for good throughout the
rest of her cinematic appearances until
she seemingly breaks bad with one
division she enslaves an entire town to
do her sitcom-oriented bidding and by
the end of the series she's acquired the
darkhold and becomes capable of
performing the darkest magic possible as
such it was understandable fans were
uneasy about where wonder's allegiances
would lie before multiverse of madness
made its way into theatres would she be
on the side of good with dr strange and
america chavez or would she join the bad
guys with the various demons featured
throughout the trailers now that the
film is out in theaters for all to see
we know she falls into the latter camp
well her motivation for travelling to a
dimension where she can be with her
children is understandable she sings to
some truly villainous means to make
those ends possible her descent into
complete madness is a shocking twist
especially when the audience finally
learns what her plan all along
throughout the movie entails
what is grief
if not love
persevering it doesn't take wanda long
to reveal her grand plan to doctor
strange she's been chasing after america
chavez for so long because she wishes to
harness her multiverse hopping abilities
for her own use you see wanda's been
having dreams of other universes out
there where different versions of her
get to live sweet domestic lives with
her children she wishes to travel into
one of these other dimensions so that
she can take another wonders place and
raise her kids in peace such an action
could lead to dire consequences but
wonder doesn't care she just wants her
children back to accomplish her goal
wonder tracks america through the
multiverse so that she can train her of
her powers to use them for her own gain
such a process will kill america but
wonder doesn't care she's made a major
heel turn from the last time we've seen
her and it all appears to be a result of
the darkhold corrupting her after all
it's not like wanda's always been this
way one could look at her character
rocking captain america civil war as
evidence of this in that film she
accidentally kills some people during
her attempt to stop some bad guys and
she feels terrible about it in that
instance she obviously knows the ends
don't justify the means and it
kickstarts the entire conflict of the
film suffice to say that's not how she
acts in this movie but her turn to
villainy will come as no surprise to
people who know the comics scarlet witch
it was fun just looking at it from a
different perspective
wanda started as a villain in the mcu
only to turn into an avenger and now in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness she's back to being the bad guy
and she does some truly horrific things
from slaughtering sorcerers at carmitage
to killing the illuminati she doesn't
allow anyone to get in her path to
capturing america it can naturally make
the audience conflicted about how to
feel about her and that's precisely the
case with her status in the marvel
comics she's done plenty of good
throughout her comic book run helping
the avengers and the x-men numerous
times however she's also caused her fair
share of problems particularly when she
becomes overly emotional this is
precisely what occurred during the
infamous house of m storyline where she
created an alternate reality that
eliminated 98 of the world's mutants
there's also the avengers disassemble
dark where she orchestrated events to
disband the avengers she did so because
she learned her children never actually
existed sound familiar and in a state of
chaos she wanted the avengers to know
precisely how she felt wanda's neither
fully a hero nor villain she pretty much
does what she wants and her allegiances
lie with whoever can help her attain
those goals doctor strange 2 presents a
more vicious wonder than anything we've
seen before in a live action setting and
is bound to unsettle audiences
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one